alors le je crois que le premier point
sur lequel sur lequel il faut réfléchir
c'est euh c'est la productivité c'est
les gains de productivité alors je vais
essayer de vous montrer des g de
productivité euh non alors c'est tu
descends avec la frence si tu descends
je pas oui ben alors c'est non mais
c'est c'est des années lumières donc euh
voilà bon je vais je je vais je vous je
vais vous montrer les gains de
productivité donc je je vais passer pleu
de slid mais voilà alors là j'ai pas
l'Europe je j'ai pas la France je vais
commenter la France mais vous voyez que
il y a il y a un écart croissant alors
c'est le niveau de la productivité du
travail hein c'est la la valeur ajoutée
par salarié et vous voyez qu'aux
États-Unis alors 2000 2020 2021 c'est
très perturbé par la la manière dont les
pays ont réagi à la crise du du covid
aux États-Unis il y a des licenciements
en Europe il y a du chômage partiel
indemnisé par l'État il faut regarder la
tendance voyez la productivité du
travail en Europe elle est légèrement
décro croissante par rapport au son
niveau de 2018-29 aux États-Unis elle
reste sur une tendance de croissance de
à peu près 1,5 % par an donc il y a une
anomalie européenne à partir de 2018 et
cette anomalie européenne elle est
particulièrement forte en France parce
que si vous comparer le niveau de
productivité du travail aujourd'hui au
niveau de productivité du travail au 2e
trimestre 2018 ce qui est le le le pic
de la productivité en France on a une
baisse de 6 % du niveau de productivité
du travail et ça c'est absolument
abominable parce que ça interdit
d'augmenter les salaires réels ça fait
ça fait subir à l'état des pertes de
recettes fiscales et et et donc il faut
absolument comprendre pour savoir si on
doit adhérer à la thèse du gouvernement
ou de la BCE qui a un retour de gain de
productivité assez fort en 2000 en 2024
2025 la BCE est encore au-dessus du
gouvernement français hein ou bien si on
va continuer à avoir une stagnation de
la productivité alors si si on compare
un scénario de stagnation de la
productivité un scénario de de retour à
la tendance de la productivité
antérieure à partir de 2024 dans dans le
scénario de stagnation de la
productivité il y a quat points de PIB
en moins en 2027 c'est-à-dire deux
points de déficit public en plus
c'est-à-dire que le déficit public
serait de pas de 2,8 % mais de 4,8 % en
2027 donc c'est c'est une question
absolument cruciale de de savoir ce
qu'on dit sur la productivité sachant
que le gouvernement français ou la BCE
on on fait l'hypothèse queil y aurait un
redémarrage assez rapide de des gains de
productivité
alors che eric veut reparler aussi mais
quel quel qu quelles sont les
explications du ralentissement de la
productivité pour moi il y a la baisse
du chômage et comme Sandrine vient de le
dire on peut pas avoir à la fois le
retour sur le marché du travail de
salariés peu qualifiés et des gains de
productivité rapide et donc il faut
choisir et on
a comme le comme le taux de chômage est
qualifié est en dessous de 4 % en France
et qu'il est très peu cyclique et donc
quand vous avez une baisse du chômage
vous avez une baisse essentiellement du
chômage des peu qualifiés qui fait
reculer la productivité globale de de de
la de la de la population active donc
première explication deuxème explication
c'est l'apprentissage il a il y a des
estimations qui disent que à peu près
entre le quart et le tiers de la perte
de gain de productivité et du est dû à
l'apprentissage mais ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que les apprentis sont
peu productifs au début et ils viendront
plus productifs plus tard et la troisème
explication c'est l'absentéisme hein il
y a il y a un taux d'absentéisme dans
les entreprises en France qui a monté de
2 points et demi entre 2018 et
aujourd'hui et qui fait baisser la durée
effective du travail he et et et qui
fait baisser la production des
entreprises on a un taux d'absentéisme
qui est de 6,5 % dans les entreprises
françaises il était de 3 % de 3,5 % il y
a a il y a moins de 10 ans et c'est un
absentéisme essentiellement des jeunes
de 20 à 35 ans et les les les vieux
comme moi travaill un peu plus prennent
moins con maladie mais les jeunes on
prennent beaucoup et et ça c'est un
problème c'est c'est un problème qui a
relié au fait qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeunes qui disent qu'il y a pas de sens
leur travail enfin il y a des enquêtes
de sociologues qui montrent qu'il y a
une perte de sens du travail une perte
d'implication dans le travail assez
forte dans les
jeunes